okay we'll start with the first the most
obvious question what what is physics
you have talked about yeah
the golden principle physics tell us
about that - yeah well the golden
principle I'm saying that physics first
of all physics is not the study of this
or is the study of that anybody can
study and not be able to explain
anything I think science let alone
physics but science is not just the
study of something it's explaining
something specially as it regards to
physics you have to explain physical
mechanisms causes that's what I think
physics is about in order to explain
causes you need to have objects and I
think the bread and butter of physics is
this word called object and to me it's
stunning that no one has figured this
out in mathematical physics since the
days of Newton at least no one has
figured out that you need an object to
do physics once you cover that stuff
you've got to define the word object and
no one has defined the word object in a
scientific way or youth or you know not
a single book in physics of physics
textbook the physics on planet Earth
begins by saying this is an object and
and this is what we're gonna do with it
in other words specifically define key
words that you need for the foundations
of physics this is an object this
distance this is a location this is what
we mean by motion you know these words
have never been defined in a scientific
way in fact Newton said he didn't know
what something with motion was and yes I
think physics is the study of causes and
mechanisms
it's not about math it's not about
measuring it's not about equations it's
about explaining a mechanism you
wouldn't explain how a magnet works you
want to explain how gravity works and in
order to do that you need objects and
you need to define what an object is so
that's in a nutshell what my vision of
physics
okay so how would you define an object
of in well you know if you look up in
the dictionary you'll find definitions
of ordinary speech not scientific
definitions in other words not one that
you can use consistently rationally and
in order to use that word consistently
scientifically rationally you have to
define it as that which has shape that's
the only property all objects have
whether imaginary objects or real
objects existing existing objects all of
them have the same property shape and
what doesn't have shape is known as a
concept essentially right I gray okay
what is mathematics and how does it
relate to facts for instance three I
talk about numbers how does this concept
relates to physical objects now I'm
saying mathematics has nothing to do
with physics or with science and people
immediately say what are you saying
no you're crazy what do you mean
mathematics has nothing to do with
science and we go back to the
definitions and just follow them
strictly what is science about what is
physics about if physics is about
explaining phenomena causes mechanisms
we have no use for mathematics
whatsoever
so in that sense mathematics has
absolutely nothing to do with physics or
with science if physics is about
explaining causes and mechanisms now if
you see if you define physics as you
know measurement equations predictions
and you know observation proof evidence
well then yes then you can bring
mathematics in and that's what's
happened what's happened is the
mathematicians have defined what science
is what physics is not the physicists
and the physicists
real fizzes and genuine physicist
defines physics a little different than
a mathematician he defines us is that
which you know as causes and mechanisms
and for that we have no use whatsoever
for mathematics because you know I mean
what does an equation do an equation is
just a description and I'm not asking
for a description I'm asking for an
explanation and and for that you need to
define the words explain and describe
and find out what the difference between
those two words is a lot of people think
there are synonyms ok so how would you
describe these words and the difference
between them in well the description is
a listing of properties you know I want
to describe a chair and I say it's got
four legs it's brown it's big it's small
I use that adjectives and I qualify it
and all I'm doing is describing I
haven't explained anything so far a an
explanation is revealing causes and
mechanisms for a phenomena you know
there was something happened and you're
gonna say how it happened meaning not a
description like yeah it fell down it
fell at 9.8 meters per second squared
now that's not an explanation I want to
know what caused it to fall down why
didn't fall down and not up for example
you know or how does a magnet attract
another you know I can't just say well
it attracted it such-and-such speed at
such-and-such distance that's not an
explanation that's just a description
and what I want is in explains I want to
know the mechanism you know like if if I
want to explain to you the mechanism
might I use this example because I guess
everybody can relate to it a pulley you
know you have a bucket you have a rope
tied to the bucket and the road goes
around the pulley the little old wheel
and you say well how did he pull the
bucket up there you know it's full of
water and how do you pull the butter
bucket up there and I show the movie I
don't even have to explain anything I
can just show the movie all objects
they're all visible and you see this guy
pulling on the Rope the Rope goes around
the police
wheel turns and the bucket goes up and
so everybody looks at that and just say
oh I understand a book the bucket ended
up up there you just pull down the rope
and that's the mechanism everybody can
understand because everything is visible
everything is visible in front of your
very own eyes and so all you got to do
is watch the movie and say I understand
the mechanism and we don't do that with
magnets we don't do that with gravity we
don't do that with light with the atomic
behavior we don't do that with
electricity what we say there are we say
oh let me describe it for you and in the
case of gravity they say mass M s is a
concepts of mathematical concept I can't
say mass did this and mass of the dead
it's like saying weight of an elephant
did this the weight squashed the ant no
it was the foot of the elephant that
squashed the end not the weight weight
has no power to do anything weight is a
mathematical concept
likewise mass is a mathematical concept
and you can't say energy because that's
another you know mathematical concept
and the problem we have today we use
these words field in force and time and
nobody has defined these terms their
concepts obvious concepts and they use
them as physical objects they tell you
oh time was warrant Oh energy we set
energy we transferred energy we moved
the mass we the force was strong very
strong force you know or whatever and so
we're using all these concepts as
physical objects we've gotten so used to
it because they're all mathematical
concepts and it's mathematicians who
have defined science not physicists in
fact if you go back to square one we go
back to Aristotle and he's the guy who
wrote the first book of physics that we
have today extant book of fessing that's
his eponymous book known as physics and
you know Aristotle says look
mathematicians do angles numbers that's
mathematicians physicists they do causes
and a lot of people criticize me and say
well bill you want to go back to the
days of Aristotle and they have to
understand the context the context is
not that we want to go back to eros
in the sense that you know maybe his
scientific method was to be desired
you know the issue is that he had the
right idea physics explains causes
that's what we forgot there's nothing
wrong with people doing experiments
there's nothing wrong with people doing
math if they want well when they come to
the conference they have to explain the
mechanism and that's what they forgot
about they do a lot of math they do a
lot of descriptions equations numbers
talk about infinity is bringing all
these fancy words like energy and field
and what they're what we're missing is
the explanation of the mechanism we
still don't know how magnet affects
another or how gravity works and this is
the issue that's why I go back to
Aristotle only on the issue of the
notion the context in intense physics is
about causes and mechanisms ok ok thank
you pass it this one ok we'll skip this
one
what do you think the proper
relationship between myth and physics
you'd be I'm saying it's none because if
if they give if we define physics as
causes and mechanisms we have no use for
math we have no use for equations n
equation cannot tell me how a mother
nature does her secret you know tasks
everyday how she does magnets is of how
she does gravity it doesn't tell me that
mathematical you know an equation can
only describe it and say look it it's
done at such and such speeds so much
time that sort of thing but he cannot
tell me the cause it cannot tell me the
mechanism and if math has no power to do
that math has nothing to do with physics
that's why it's important to define what
is physics about
it's okay what do you say to those who
think what do you say to those who say
that science is all about prediction and
not explaining stuff people do say that
of course and I and I know you're gonna
disagree a bit it goes back to the gift
of that same definition why why did the
word prediction enter the world of
science the world of physics well
because mathematics can predict nothing
wrong with that we're saying that if I
use the example carbon goes at 50 miles
per hour okay well you can predict that
even one hour it'll be 50 miles away
that's straightforward right and so
there's nothing wrong with any of that
it's predictable the question is we
still don't have a mechanism we don't
know why the the cheetah is running at
60 miles per hour or whatever you know
we don't have the mechanism we have is a
description and that's all that a
prediction is a prediction I'm not
saying that you know like I'll give you
an example I can predict that tomorrow
two o'clock there's gonna be an eclipse
okay so it turns out that you wait till
tomorrow to a clog and effectively you
have any clips so I've predicted the
Eclipse I what did I say I say
something's going to happen what's going
to happen there's gonna be an eclipse so
far they have not explained the reason
the cause all I have done is described
that this is what's going to happen I
still don't know why it's gonna happen
what caused it to happen
all I know is that it's going to happen
that's a description if you can explain
why what causes an eclipse now you're
talking about the past you're no longer
talking about a prediction which it has
to do with the future you're talking
about an explanation and you can only
explain and consummated the event what
am I saying I'm saying that this guy has
already the guy who does this prediction
and can explain why it's going to
and he's already seen he's already had
some experience with this event he saw
it in a movie maybe he's an astronomer
and watched eclipses in the past so he
can explain why he said well you know
what's happening is the moon goes in
between the Sun and the earth that's why
that's why the the the sky goes dark so
now he's already had experience with it
we're talking about the past we're
talking about a consummated event that
he's now regurgitating that's why he can
explain it if he cannot explain it if he
can just say predict and say it's going
to happen or he has a description there
is no explanation at that up to that
point we have no mechanism
okay um okay some people have accused
you of being hostile towards meth would
you like to comment on this
I hate a lot you know I've done
gazillions of math courses in my life so
I'm very well-versed in math I just
abandoned it because I realized math
only gets in the way and so I have no
problem with math I do understand math I
consider myself pretty good
mathematicians I have this natural knack
to do calculations in my head I rarely
use a calculator and you know it's just
one of those things I'm good at just by
birth you know I've always been
mathematically inclined in that sense I
just don't use math because I do physics
now and I see that math only gets in the
way and so in that sense again I go back
to the definition of physics what is
physics about if it's about mechanisms
and causes we have no use for math
whatsoever and people have a hard time
understanding that because for 400 years
at least since the days of Newton and
even maybe before with Galileo they've
been harping on math and they've been
harping on measurement and I'm saying
math and measurement have nothing to do
with explanations of causes and
mechanisms that's the relation okay I
think I can I think you can like this
one please tell us about your views of
quantum theory and relativity
I think you've a lot to say on this
whenever you like
you have to keep in mind first at least
the way I understand it since the 17th
century of so-called scientific
revolution I think these people were
genuine the original people you know
that you look up in those days you have
Gilbert you have Torricelli's all these
people did otto a1 Gary K all these
people did experiments and why did they
do experiments well partly because they
never study
nature they were trying to figure out
you know how this universe works and
they say look how interesting
look this effect over here you know
static electricity look at this other
one lighted it refracts and so on okay
fine I think they were originally trying
to get to the bottom of things trying to
explain how this universe how this
universe works in a rational way in a
way we can all understand and again I go
back to making movies you've got to be
able to visualize the mechanism I think
they were interested in doing that but
they couldn't figure it out and we
lasted like that all the way in the 19th
century end of the 19th century all the
1800s and that's and when we came up
with quantum at the beginning of the
20th century 1900 mr. Max Planck after
that we abandon slowly gradually more so
to these days we abandoned what we call
today classical mechanics which is think
of it as rational mechanics people
trying to answer you know what causes
things how does this universe really
work and we got into quantum mechanics
and we got into general relativity and
what do they do well I say that the word
quantum doesn't mean packet it doesn't
mean bundle of energy I say the word
quantum means irrational that's what it
means every time someone says quantum
mechanics he's saying irrational
mechanics why because all the
explanations without exception a lot of
quantum mechanics are all irrational
they all have the movement of concepts
that's one problem the other problem
probably just as bad is they tell you
mechanisms that are clearly irrational a
particle can be at two places at once
now what the sense does that make and
the worst part is that you know the
mathematicians who subscribe to quantum
they say oh we know it's irrational in
other words they mean they they say it
in a different way they say we don't
understand how quantum works how that
subatomic world works
we just theorize and their theories are
all irrational there are physical
interpretations their mechanisms are all
irrational
a particle can be at two places at once
you have what is called entanglement
this particle over here can affect this
other particle over there there's
nothing in between it just does it by
magic spirits or whatever in between and
I have all these irrational explanations
general relativity very similar why
doesn't the earth fly out of the solar
system because you have this thing this
thing very quotations on that thing
called space-time four dimensional space
four dimensional what is that I can't
picture it oh no don't try to imagine
for a dimensional space-time because
nobody can we have this three
dimensional mind where these puny little
humans and we have no way of seeing this
this immense four dimensional object
whatever that we're in and when you say
well hold in time as a concept and space
if it's an equivalent with nothing with
vacuum it's also a concept and so we
have two concepts and we're making the
object and we live within this
unimaginable object-- and so again both
spite general relativity and quantum
mechanics have only irrational
explanations black holes dark matter
conveniently invisible conveniently
heavy conveniently sprinkled wherever
you need to explain something involving
mass you know and you say well is is
this the way you universe works and
that's when you start doubting you know
the physical interpretations of these
two you know calm discipline swirl so
that I don't offend them we call them
religions you know they don't have
rational explanations and that's my take
on quantum mechanics and general
relativity they have no rational
explanation we still don't understand
how this universe works
for all those invisible phenomena for
all those phenomena in which there's an
invisible mediator gravity light
electricity magnetism we don't we don't
understand how they work and general
relativity and quantum mechanics will
not help you because they can only offer
you no irrational explain each the
particle
two places at or as this particle
effects the other one from a distance
there's nothing in between except
spirits and space-time is unimaginable
and it's four-dimensional and so it's
all the rations you cannot picture any
of it that's my take yeah it's basically
a bunch of really really bad mathematics
and that's about it
do we even need to talk about string
theory commits Polyphemus not even
that's not even wrong so there's a
couple things about string theory the
first thing a string theory has nothing
to do with a rope model that I have
three theories uh is a mathematical
theory not a physical theory okay and
what the string theory is trying to do
the reason it came to be is that it
tried to merge or find some common
ground freshing relation to gravity
between quantum mechanics and general
relativity general relativity has
equations related to fields and quantum
mechanics as specifically the
Schrodinger equation which tells you
something about this subatomic world
where the electron can be found around
the atom and they say okay so we have
this micro world here with this macro
world over here the equations are
totally different they describe
different things how do we get them
together and so strength theory came in
and says well we're gonna try to put
them together and what strength theory
does for what it's trying to do is what
is known as quantization of space-time
they're trying to get the micro world of
quantum mechanics okay into a point that
is used to build four-dimensional
space-time think of it as space-time and
we can't picture this whole thing but
what we can do is look at a little piece
of space-time so what is in this little
piece well let's take it all the way
down to the tiniest you know a region
that we can imagine and that's where
quantum can be put in there because now
this region can be treated with quantum
effects and that's what they've tried to
do
now the first thing you need to
understand about that is that space-time
already was quantized the the bread and
butter of space-time in that sense is
the point it's known as the event event
is a point in space-time what does that
mean it means that you can locate the
happening the occurrence the event
something that happened within space
night you can locate that with four
coordinates one time and supposedly the
three dimensions physical dimensions
length width and height really actually
they're talking about coordinates are
talking about longitude latitude and
altitude plus time they call those four
number lines which is what they really
are talking about those four number
lines they call it four dimensional
space-time and that's how you locate a
point what is that point that's the
point that we're going to analyze with
quantum mechanics and that's what string
theory is trying to do it's trying to
merge the world of the smaller the world
of the big and for this they created the
line nothing went from the point of the
line you know geometry you have the
point and you have the line right what
is the line well the line is a point
that's moving somewhere you know
hopefully in a straight line and so the
bread and butter of string theory is the
line is it a three dimensional string or
something no it's a one-dimensional line
one dimension are we talking about
length width height are we talking about
longitude latitude altitude
none of those what they're talking about
is a number line they're saying that
something moves and traces a path now
they turn that path into a line so
geometric line they say okay now this
thing is one-dimensional it's not two or
three dimensional and we're going to
deal with that line and that's what
we're gonna construct our new math is
and that's essentially what string
theory does
I don't know if it makes sense but
that's that's what string theory does
and that's what all the equations in
string theory are about they take those
paths then and they build brains with
that and that's another monster oh man
do with physics I don't forget all your
other nine ten twenty dimensions we
weren't going to there's yes whatever
whatever that means
okay now good stuff now onto some of
your idea is tell us about the Rope
hypothesis tell us about some of the
great mysteries it will be understood
phenomena that explains well the Rope
model originally you know when I came up
with it I was able to explain two things
to my satisfaction when one was light
and the other one was gravity and
gravity came like you know second hint I
had originally came up with my notion of
gravity and that was that all these
lines you know if two objects come
together assuming that all these lines
connect at every atom well then as the
two objects approach each other these
lines would fan out and when the objects
got farther away from each other you
know the lines would come in closer and
act as one eventually you know I've had
a great distance and I like that concept
then I came up with a rope model
separate you know that was a separate
train of thought and and that one said
you know you have a rope here I have my
famous rope I don't know you can see it
hopefully okay and what it is is I'm
saying it's a torsion along the rope and
if you look at a torsion right you can
call it a torque wave it's a three
dimensional wave along a rope not a two
dimension or one dimensional
longitudinal wave it's a three
dimensional wave and what it is is
essentially a torsion along a three
dimensional object the object is simply
twisting or torquing in place and if you
run the experiment at home you know just
tie rope to to to to
walls or to posts or whatever and you
hang to clothespins very dangerous very
expensive experiment right take the
grandmas clothesline just put two
clothes pins there and you move one of
them the other one moves you could say
instantaneously it just moves yeah you
know torsion is instantaneous and what
this tells you is that wide light is so
fast if light is a transverse wave it's
slow if it's a longitudinal wave it
would be slow if it's a torsion it's the
fastest thing you can imagine and so
that's one issue the other one issue is
that you know now we can explain the
Maxwell's equations with it because now
you have what is known until today as
magnetic field in an electric field what
they've been describing all these days
is a magnetic thread and an electric
thread and these two threads are twined
around each other and they have confused
that with two plane transverse waves and
so I'm replacing their the model right
now with a rope I'm saying it's it's a
physical rope that connects any two
atoms so when one atom expands and
contracts it tortes the rope by torquing
the rope the signal goes to the other
atom and the good thing about torsion is
it travels both ways so both atoms
receive the signal irrespective and
they're constantly receiving gnats at
the speed of light because again torsion
travels extremely fast and so we can
explain speed we can explain other
phenomena like C equals frequency times
wavelength the fact that frequency is
inversely proportional to wavelength the
more the longer the wave the fewer links
you have a longer given length of rope
and the more you torque it
the shorter are your links and the
mornings you have and there you have
frequency times wavelength which is
equal to the constant known as the
velocity of light which is 300,000
kilometers per second so we can explain
many things
with it of course I can also explain
electricity the merged electron shells
they the whole thing twirls I call it a
serpentine you know they're just you
have a whole bunch of atoms actually
molecules but with atom that's easier to
visualize yeah well these merged shells
electron shells and when one twirls the
whole thing twirls and I'm saying that's
what electricity is when it does so it
swings threads that comprised the rope
around itself and that's gonna be the
magnetic field which goes at 90 degrees
to the electricity so you have
electricity in one direction and you
have the threads moving around the other
direction and that's going to be the
magnetic field that causes a force on
things and so you know it's a
self-consistent model you can explain
gravity you can explain light in its
plane magnetic field you can explain
electricity all with the same model it's
just a different model out there and
what I always try to emphasize is that
the issue is not to try to convince
people the issues were people to
understand the mechanism which I can
illustrate you know I illustrate that I
show it there what people want to
believe that's their personal opinion
the issue is that they can look at it
objectively and say okay I understand
what he's proposing whether you like it
or not whether it violates your religion
I don't know that's your personal issue
you know but I can explain these
different mechanisms these invisible
mechanism with a single model okay
what is the big experimental evidence
for the upon the fifth Oh what
experiments would you like to see in the
future if they had not been done yet
okay first in science we don't produce
evidence for what I just said the issue
is not to try to convince people and
that's what evidence is used for a
prosecutor comes to the court and he
tries to persuade the jury to vote for
his side of the case how does he do it
he presents evidence he presents maybe
testimony from experts expert testimony
he presents a materia
things you know the knife whatever he's
through there how the person was killed
he presents evidence and evidence is the
only purpose of evidence is to persuade
we don't do that in science we do that
in religion in science we just present a
mechanism objectively so I'm going to
clarify that point first second I'll say
that if you want evidence the evidence
is every experiment we've done today we
have already did we have already made
practically every experiment that we can
think of out there we've done the slit
experiment we've done polarization
Compton effect we have the photoelectric
of we have all these experiments already
done now we have to explain them and so
it's not an issue of evidence
it's what mechanism can you come and
explain these different experiments that
have already been done how can we
explain them objectively so that someone
understands the mechanism say okay I see
what Mother Nature is doing here with
all these her invisible stuff and all
you want to do is explain it they can't
make in this mechanistically okay so
that people look at it objectively and
say okay I understand it doesn't mean
you're gonna believe it it means you
understand it that's it that's where
science dies then after that you have
religion and then the final issue is
that I have come up with a new
experiment that is distinguishes between
the wave the transverse wave okay and
the rope if light is a rope it's not a
transverse wave you know which is simply
a concept there's no such thing as a
wave the transverse wave of quantum
mechanics is a bunch of vectors it they
only have magnitude and direction if you
look at that wave that they always show
you look at it closely you'll see arrows
what are each one of those arrows
magnitude and direction that's all it is
it's a mathematical concept there is no
stand-alone object I can bring put on
the table called waves trying to
persuade no such thing okay so the the
rope model is different in that sense so
what experiment
right well I'm saying that there's one
experiment that I don't think people
have tried I don't know anyone who has
done it and I've come up with this
experiment and it's the slit in a vacuum
that's what I call it
you take the slit experiment and you put
the whole contraption under vacuum
why because quantum mechanics will tell
you that if you remove material from
that chamber where you're gonna do this
slit experiment you remove material from
there the mean free path is going to
increase the photons now have nothing to
bounce against because you removed all
the matter that was in its way so what
should you see at the end of you know
where the slit experiment for those who
are not familiar with it you run light
monochromatic light through two slits
and instead of seeing two lines on the
screen you see fringes you see many
lines okay and so the question is you
know how does Mother Nature do this
magic and I'm saying let's put that
whole setup under vacuum what happens if
you put it under vacuum now we remove
matter from a chamber that means the
mean free path increases and it means
that now according to quantum mechanics
right the intensity should increase
because there are more photons reaching
the screen reaching you know wherever or
whatever wherever you see there the
fringes there should be more photons
hitting that area that the intensity
should increase and you can measure that
with a photosensitive manner you know
multiply or whatever the rope model says
something differently it says that light
is relayed from atom to atom okay so
that means if you remove atoms from the
chamber you're reducing the amount of
atoms that are relaying the signal to
the screen the intensity should go down
so I think that would be an experiment
that someone who has the equipment
should run and say well it does like
consist of little part
if it consists of little particles and
you remove all the obstacles there
should be a higher intensity rope model
says look all atoms are interconnected
by a rope like mechanism wrote like
mediator and if you remove the atoms
there's still your ropes crisscrossing
the chamber but now you don't have that
relay going to the screen and the
intensity should remain the same or drop
and so that's the difference between
those two it you know the experiment
would I think decide between those two
it's got to be done very carefully one
thing you got to be aware of is that
photo multipliers are I use them you
know and they're designed to count blips
as particles and that's already against
the Rope model because it's already
predetermined these these devices you
know they're already assuming a particle
world and so photomultiplier that's why
they call it a multiplier or
sensitometer and that's already you know
against the rope model
okay what kind of support does your rope
model have have you had any success and
getting any academic support for your
for your model we're current it's pretty
hard cuz it disagrees with his disagrees
with the mainstream a lot so I'm I
imagine there's some difficulty there
would you like to talk about that yeah
there's no support whatsoever because
people don't know about it that's the
problem and you can't get it the people
to know about it because it's a
qualitative type issue I'm saying look
we can explain this universe at least
one model can and that's the rope model
and that's I can explain mechanistically
I can explain to you on the board how
gravity works with this model I can
explain light electricity magnets and I
can explain all this and you don't have
to take my word for you just have to
watch the movie you know I'm not gonna
tell you look it's not imagine what's
four dimensional you can't see it it's
zero dimensional like or one dimensional
like its string theory no I'm saying
look I'm talking about a three
dimensional rope just like I'm saying
here and it's invisible because very
thin very small you know and so yeah you
can't see all this but here's the
mechanism do you understand the making
it so I can illustrate what I'm talking
about
but what happens that's a qualitative
issue and the mathematicians for the
last hundred years are already on record
that there's no way you can explain the
mechanism of this universe
they're already on record saying no no
this world works irrationally or better
yet they they don't like to say
irrational obviously they say look it
works in ways that we cannot understand
we cannot explain how how this quantum
world works we can describe it look
here's the equation here are the numbers
here's the measurements but we don't
know how mother nature does how can a
particle be at two places at once well I
don't know you know they don't ask me
just take math and you'll understand it
that's that's the issue and so what
happens the people who control the
literature the publishing world are all
mathematicians essentially people who've
been brain
watch generation after generation after
generation now for the last hundred
years so what happens you know I
submitted articles I submitted to
science I submitted to nature and I get
a polite no message back saying well you
know editorial space is limited in blah
blah blah and we only have space you
know for nonsense we have met and that's
how what they said but this is my
interpretation we have space for black
holes we you know magical black holes we
have space for dark matter we have space
for particles that travel backwards in
time we have space for European in
different universes you know what I call
is the term alternative realities that's
what they call it we have space for all
that but we don't have space for
rational stuff you know and and they
think they're arrogant just because you
think you can answer how this universe
how this universe works objectively they
say that's impossible only God knows
that and so they don't publish
qualitative stuff you read any paper in
the literature today it's all math it's
all equations that's my nobody who reads
that no one in the general public who
reads that nonsense because it's all
just math taken to ridiculous levels
today you read any of those papers just
equations equations equation equations
you don't see any pictures in there so
you can't understand any you can't
visualize anything because there's
nothing to visualize because they're not
concerned about qualitative explanations
about causes about you know mechanisms
and so when you submit a paper talking
about qualitative stuff in a they reject
it immediately because they say look
classical mechanics died in the 19th
century where have you been in the last
hundred years and that's the issue the
issue is they won't publish anything
that deals with qualitative stuff
anymore and and there's no way to get
that in there so so though we get this
irony where people go to Quora for
example which is a site where you ask
questions and you try to get answers and
99.99 percent of the people go in there
that ask questions of physics and they
ask questions like you know how does a
man
how does gravity work they want to see a
qualitative explanation and they don't
realize first that they're asking the
wrong people second these people are
saying in so many words that we don't
understand how any of this works you
want to understand it take a math
courses at the university level and so
the person's you know they ask a
question they've never get an answer is
oh I'm so puny I don't understand any of
this you know and they say thank God we
have all these mathematicians that do
all the thinking for us they understand
all of it and the mathematicians are
telling them in their face we don't
understand how this universe works
we can only describe it and so we have
this this runaround you know this this
is the world we live it yeah yeah I look
at some those questions on quorum yet
the answer the horrible em well if you
want to call the man says I mean you
won't get an answer you won't get an
answer from any of these people there
whatever answer they give you for sure
120% is irrational in other words you
won't be able to picture it whether it's
quantum or general relativity you will
not be able to picture it because as
soon as you picture it they'll say oh
you took the analogy too seriously too
literally
you know you're not supposed to take it
this is a mathematical description and
the only we can put into words is you
know by giving you you know the warp
space you know the or canvas analogy we
can only give you you know particle
going backwards in time you know we can
paint the two particles on the screen in
the same look your particles have two
places at once and everybody looks and
says are these two particles no there's
just one particle but there are two
different location how can that be well
that's you got to take math to
understand and so they give you a
rational explanation they tell you they
don't understand that they cannot
explain in words because they can only
express it mathematically through
equations and numbers and people are not
listening to that they're saying oh
these people are so smart you know
look they understand all this - I don't
but they must understand it because look
they can express it in
and that's what we have that's the word
roll today hmm okay are there any
criticisms of the rope motor would you'd
like to address here
well the rope model is a simple too
simple for people to really say no I'm
not going to take it seriously
this is kindergarten stuff and it is
because physics is kindergarten stuff
look I always say I like this because
it's it's simple and I use this just
came from a conference in Sweden and I
showed this and here's you see those
little if you're seeing that's right you
see those two little magnets in these
plastic holders right and put them
together and they stick together okay
very simple experiment now this is the
entire system the entire system consists
essentially of those two little pieces
of metal that's it that's that's how
simple this is now I asked people do you
really believe you need to take calculus
at the university level or linear
algebra or whatever do you need to take
all this math to explain a simple system
here we have just two magnets coming
together that's the entire system two
pieces of metal they attract each other
you would think that all you need to do
is figure out what invisible thing is
here between these two magnets I can
already feel them pulley to each other
all you got explained or in other words
all you really got to do is make visible
what you think mother nature has between
those two magnets and because that's the
entire system if these were the only two
things in the universe how does mother
nature do this and the only way you're
gonna figure it out by making the
invisible visible you got to make
whatever object and mother nature's
using it this is a born then you'll
understand the mechanism and I'm saying
this is done with in this case with
threads Nessa long story but it has to
do with the rope model you cannot do
action at a distance unless you have
some elongated
medium such as a rope then you can
explain gravity and you can explain some
of these mechanisms if you're gonna use
particles discrete particles there's no
way you can produce attraction
especially I can't throw particles at
you and pull you I don't throw rocks at
a donkey to pull it I tie a rope around
its neck and pull it then we can
understand pull but it doesn't work by
throwing rocks I tried it you know the
poor dog ends up with a lot of bumps
okay are there any good books on we can
read about the right model I think there
are a couple can do we got to talk about
those or you mention a movie anything
anyone can look at to learn more I'm
sure that there are lots of lots of
people on my a park I threw it
interested in really more about this
yesterday I was talking a little bit
about that the fact that you know I used
to be a Marxist at one time and when I
was the age of 17 I read the Scottie
tiles from Marx and that's a monster
it's a big book like that and a lot of
people get scared when they see a book
that thick and they you got to be brave
to read something like that another book
is the Bible I read it three times and
again it's a very thick book and I love
the Bible you know not because I'm
religious but because I like it as a
historical book and and this is my book
it's another monster it's I don't know
is that it upside down there I don't
know in the screen it shows the opposite
but it says why God doesn't exist and
you can see by the thickness that is a
pretty thick book it's 514 pages and
what's the issue the issues here is you
know the entire model of the rope and
yeah it's just uh
not everybody can read 514 pages a lot
of those you know have pictures I have
over 200 pictures because it's a very
pictorial theory you can look at the
pictures and understand it pretty much
and you know the words are there just to
help you understand what you're looking
at right I also have videos and so on
but the point is you know not everybody
reads a 500 page
these days everybody wants the Twitter
version no one liner you know Tony tell
me how this works and get it over with
and you know some things are more
accomplished you got to know you know
what Neutron bombardment is you need to
understand what you know what an object
is in fact you need to lay the
foundations of physics in order to reach
some of these higher-level concepts and
for that you really need to read and
people just want to a quick version
doesn't always work that way but why God
doesn't exist and again people focus on
the word God no you should work focus on
the word exist that's what the book is
about because physics is the science of
existence physics only studies that
which exists and so you got to
understand what an object is and what
exists means you know here you have
atheists and theists they've been
arguing for the last thousand years
about whether God exists or not nobody
can define the word exist you look up
the word exist nobody has a definition
that you can you know solid scientific
definition and I have to define the word
exists for the purposes of physics
because physics is the science of
existence and that's what the book is
essentially about it talks about what
exists and I'm saying what is this is
especially all this invisible stuff that
we can't see I'm saying that that's
mediated by elongated objects that look
like DNA fact I think DNA copied its
format its structural architecture from
the rope model which is what light is I
think it's all related there you know
okay and who is some of your favorite
physicists and your least favorite way
well I'm saying that we don't have any
physicists well we have as
mathematicians yeah you can go back in
time find people like Galileo and Newton
and Leibniz and Huygens Christian
Huygens Allen guy and I think they were
trying to get to the bottom of things I
think they were trying to understand and
that's commendable you know I mean these
guys were the first people who really
came out of the Dark Ages you can say
they they were trying to understand how
this universe works and they through
theories they were brainstorming and
they wrote books they criticized each
other but I think they were trying to
get to the bottom of things and we lost
that scientific spirit in the 20th
century when we went into quantum yeah
people like Niels Bohr and Heisenberg
they they try to understand but they
wouldn't took us off on a totally bogus
tangent and that's that they went in
there and they said look let's try to
imagine what's there in this little
invisible world and what is there
particles and today we've evolved from
there and we said well what is a
particle and the guy says well you know
it's not this corpuscle that we had in
the days of classical mechanics rational
mechanics now we have an irrational
version of the corpuscle it's a
vibrating field in other words the
famous corpuscle of today the quantum
corpuscle is made out of verbs out of
motion so what is it that's moving well
you know it's just a verb we see the
verb precedes the noun in quantum
mechanics and that's where we have a
problem because it's all irrational then
you know you don't see the object maybe
you're not supposed to see an object
you're supposed to understand it
mathematically but what we have is the
vibration of an equation you have this
wave function what is vibrating the
function
what the hell and so yeah I don't have
too many favourite so-called physicists
because they are physicists so this is a
guy who can explain a mechanism not a
guy who can describe it mathematically
and what we've done the last hundred
years at me is it's just described and
so I don't consider any of them
physicists I dismiss them as
mathematicians I call Mathemagician x'
they do everything with magic never
imagined a doodle with the rational
explanations not even magic continue
next week and you waver you ready after
some of these so sure I thought you
probably would okay I guess we can try
this one I think that's pretty obvious
but do you think do you think what if
the fix of the dead end so core physics
whatever you want to call it mathematics
mathematical physics is that a dead end
from a conceptual point of view they
cannot explain it we'll never be able to
explain they admit they cannot explain
but you can divide a lot of these people
into two camps one group says we'll
never be able to explain we don't have
the intelligence to understand how this
universe works because our minds are not
built to understand it because you can
say that we are stuck in this limited
three-dimensional world and the universe
is actually four-dimensional 5:26
dimension or whatever it's beyond our
comprehension we'll never be able to
understand how this universe works and
then there's the other group says well
I'll keep sending the money and we're
gonna investigate someday we'll
understand and so I think that's that's
how mathematical physics is divided
today in these two groups and you know
it's it's just they're at a dead end in
that sense they cannot explain gravity
and they cannot merge
the equations of general relativity with
the equations of quantum mechanics you
know they they cannot merge them that's
what strain theory is trying to do so
what happens in that sense the rather
dead end they say don't expect anything
because we cannot uncomplicated physics
once we figure out physics how this
universe works were done with physics
there's no more physics after that once
we understand how mother nature runs or
father universe runs his shop we're done
you know we just understand say okay now
we understand what this universe is how
gravity is done how light is done how
electricity add on magnetism so we're
done now we understand and we have no
more physics after that we can shut down
all the accelerators on earth we can
shut down NASA completely in the
european space agency in the japanese
space agency chinese indian all of them
why we're going nowhere we're going
nowhere we're not gonna we're not going
to inhabit the solar system we're not
going to expand into another planet
we're not going to terraform another
plan we're not gonna go to another star
there's no possibility of any of that
happening we die here on earth and so
again I think we're just spending money
in a lot of this stuff simply party to
keep a lot of these mathematical physics
physicists occupied giving them a job
but what are they doing there they're
just telling you you know we cannot
figure this out they cannot figure out
the problem out there they don't have
solutions physical solution they have
mathematical solution but knowing the
physical solution so in that sense yeah
physics that the mathematical physics
has that a dead end and with a rope
model the way I look at it is that if
that's the way the universe works we're
done we know how the universe works
mechanics mechanistically and there's no
more science after that once you figure
that out yeah you can go into more
detail and say well how does levitation
work like you have a magnet floating
over another you say well this is a
special case of magnetism how do you
explain as well yeah and some people go
in there and go into deeper little
things that they want to try to explain
I think the main points how magnet
attracts another how gravity works those
I think are covered with a rope model
and it's coming from a mechanistic point
of view you understand it you're done
whether you believe it or not well your
your challenge is to come up with an
alternative model mechanistic model that
replaces or that fights against the rope
model without any magic and that's the
challenge you know but other than that
I'm saying that one way or the other
physics is as it is at a dead end
okay okay what do you make of black
holes they claim to have taken a picture
of what Haftar oh wow it I give you the
image of that don't make me laugh
black holes see people are so much into
black holes and I know this because you
put you answer a question about black
holes and you get a million hints you
talk about how does electricity work you
get one here two hits and nobody cares
how do I trust you works no one cares
how a magnet attracts another but you
talk about time you talk about black
holes dark matter man everybody is an
expert everybody knows everything about
it so what is a black hole well you got
all these bright celebrities today and
Brian green he does he's a celebrity of
you know poster boy for mathematical
physics michio kaku another big name
rising star Shawn Carol Lawrence Krauss
all these our names are coming up that
some someone or other has heard about
here or there you know just about
everyone has heard about one of these
guys out there and in these people you
know they're all black holders they're
all dark and dark energy years there are
all dark matters they believe in all
this stuff so what is a black hole what
is dark matter what is dark energy and
you know these people have been
interviewed and they told they don't
know what a black hole is and it's not
surprising because a black hole is not
something it's not a what black hole is
a concept some mathematical concept it's
a it starts out with a star more massive
than a Sun then our Sun that means it's
got more matter than a Sun because it's
got so much matter it compresses
gravitationally okay it's drawn into its
center but unlike a normal star like our
Sun you know it comes to a certain it
doesn't have enough mana to squash it
beyond a certain
and it ends up being a little ball dart
ball some kind right but a black hole is
a star that is so big it just continues
compressing and listen carefully it
compresses until it crushes all matter
out of existence there is no matter what
it does is crushes all matter to a point
a zero dimensional volume there is no
structure left but this structure has
lots of energy but in lots of mass all
right well energy loss but it's got lots
of mass so you think of it as an
elephant which weighs six tons so you
crush the elephant to a point so that
there's no more elephant you got zero
volume but you still have the six tonnes
and now with these six tonnes you move
around you can do all kinds of magic
also through magic you know you can move
ants around how did the man move well
it's the six tonnes here that are moving
the ant over here and you say by what
physical mechanism did it do it and
that's where they fail because they say
what's done through mass you gotta take
a course in math at the university level
to see to show you how mass affects
something at a distance but that's a
description you still haven't told me
the mechanism of how a zero-dimensional
ultra massive object if you can call it
an object it's really a concept how that
mechanistically affects an ant over here
and so black hole is not a physical
object you can't bring a standalone
model of a black hole and put it in the
middle of the room at the conference and
say that's a black hole point to it what
are you going to point to it the zero
dimensional and then of course you got
all those mathematicians who say well
it's not really zero God mention is not
really made of nothing but we got a
problem with that because mr.
Chandrasekhar who won the Nobel Prize
for this proved mathematically that a
star B are the certain weight
certain amount of matter collapses to a
zero dimensional volume in its all mass
that's what he won the Nobel Prize for
now these people want to turn it back
and say well you misinterpreted you you
didn't understand there's nothing to
understand he can win a Nobel Prize for
saying that a black hole is zero that
mentioning volume that has tons of mass
that's that's what a black hole is and
so you know we have a non object is it
zero volume structure has been crushed
out of existence and all we have is mass
a mathematical concept and that's what a
black hole is and that's why no one can
tell you what a black hole is and the
punchline is that it's a circular
argument because when you go to high
school college they tell you well what
is mask can you define what mass is well
mass is the amount of matter or a
measure of the amount of matter in an
object and here mr. Chandrasekhar says
all matter has been crushed out of
existence but we still have mass so what
is a black hole it's a bunch of mass no
matter and then you got to define mass
what is mass and they have all these at
least seven definitions of what mass is
out there you can use any one you want
to make your case and you're you're okay
nobody'll challenge a contradiction and
of course it's not rational no longer
rational what is rational need you know
it's important to define the word
rational because I'm saying that science
is rational explanations of mechanist
their mechanisms in the case of physics
so rational explanations well what does
rational mean I mean rational bill is
your your opinion well we have to
distinguish good and bad right wrong
correct and correct true false from
rational irrational rational irrational
have objective criteria and people say
how can that possibly that's your
opinion bill yeah there is rational
criteria yeah
you can take this to whatever limit you
want but rational criterias are swallows
the first point you cannot move an
abstract concept in physics for the
purposes of physics I cannot say that
love moves mountains not literally not
in physics I can say that a heart moves
mountains because a heart is a physical
object a mountain is a physical object I
cannot say that a concept such as love
moves amount I cannot say that I worked
time with gravity I cannot say that I
pushed a mass I cannot say that I
transferred information or energy
mathematical physics only has irrational
proposals because they are in the
business of moving concepts and that's
the first criterion for objective
criteria for irrationality a second one
is using undefined words or using worse
inconsistently you have a definition
here another one there case in point the
word point what is a point
well I have you going into geometry you
go into mathematics they'll say well the
point is what is a point and the guy
says let me show you and it takes the
chalk and hits the board the blackboard
he says that's a point okay a dot well
not really see a point is really a
location location
well really it's a set of coordinates so
you take these two coordinates and
whatever is there at where these two
crisscross that's what we call the point
but what happened to the bad well you're
taking it too literally you know the
point is not the dot don't look at the
dot the dot is there to represent the
point and so it's a circular argument
they're not using the term consistently
they're putting a dot you understand
that means you can see and they say well
but don't worry about the dot that that
is just a pictorial representation of
what a point is and so it's a circular
argument and they're not using their
terms consistently and again you know
you'll find that they don't have a
definition
word energy they don't have a little
definition for the word mass and they
don't use these terms consistently and
that's another objective criteria for
what is irrational and then a third one
that I usually mentioned is that the
theory doesn't follow from the
hypothesis from the assumptions the
prosecutor he presents a knife at the
beginning of his case and here is the
life he please' exhibit one Paul puts it
on a judge's desk and then he goes with
its theory and he says in this and the
victim was poisoned to death we mean he
was poisoned to death he presented a
knife and you talk about poison so the
theory doesn't follow from the
assumption and that's also irrational so
there are criteria for what is rational
what is irrational in physics okay and
so yeah physical interpretations have to
be rational in order to be part of
rational physics otherwise we have
irrational I don't call it physically I
call it religion
okay I got a question for one of my
listeners here
how does rope theory explain the results
of ritual sins and from infer ometer
experiments it indicated that there was
no medium through which we travel the
rope theory seems like a medium
well the mic michelson-morley experiment
I think you're referring to yeah that's
the one sorry michelson-morley yeah they
did their ether experiment I think their
final one or the most important one was
in 1887 and yeah what they did they had
this interferometer and they sent light
in different directions and they found
out that in one direction as well as in
the other direction didn't matter which
way they the earth was moving etc there
was no ether wind in other words there
was no background of what the ether is
essentially is a bunch of particles
that's all
theif there is everybody that mentions
the word ether is referring to directly
or indirectly yet implicitly to a bunch
of particles that form like a background
okay and the issue is that yeah there is
no background in that sense what it is
what you have is atoms that are moving I
can't say through space because space is
not a medium space is absolutely nothing
vacuum emptiness I say I define it as
that which has no shape if something is
that which has shape
nothing is its antithesis it's that
which has no shape and so now we can use
these terms consistently and so there is
no such thing as space and therefore
there is no such thing as ether that
fills space my universe the one that I'm
proposing through the rope model is
atoms connected by interconnected
they're all all atoms are interconnected
by what I call electromagnetic ropes
that means there's this twined double
thread right two threads they're twined
and they connect every atom in the
universe and what happens is the atom
now moves slides along the rope as it
eats rope and yeah but happen again a
picture's worth a thousand words if you
look at my model if you look it up there
you'll see that the rope itself makes
the atom so think of sliding a bead
along an Abbott
the beat slides along the wire there it
doesn't eat up the wire in other words
it just slides along and the wire goes
behind it and that's more or less what's
happening with the rope model the atom
is made of these threads itself and as
the atom glides through the Rope the
rope goes around it and behind it so the
atom is sliding along the ropes at the
same time it's pumping and torquing the
rope
there's several mechanisms there that
are going on simultaneously and again
you would have to look at the model from
a pictorial point of view so that you
know you understand it much better than
being able to explain it so what happens
is if an atom slides along now of course
there's no ether there's no resistance
light always travels at the same speed
no matter what direction no matter what
no matter what material it goes through
see we have something called refractive
index and that's important in this
context the worldly wisdom today is that
when light goes from a lighter medium
from a dense less dense medium to a
denser medium like from air into glass
or into water you know we know it
refracts you put a pencil in water and
you see that the pencil is broken
that's called refraction and how does
Mother Nature do that little you know
magic and people say well very easily
the light is traveling at a different
speed in this denser medium that's the
explanation we have today and for this
we created a big table known as
refractive index for every material we
have to have a different speed of light
the rope model has something a different
proposal it says look light always
travels at the same speed from atom to
atom anywhere in the universe between
any two atoms I don't care what the atom
belongs to if it belongs to a crystal to
metal the water to air it doesn't matter
like between any two atoms always
300,000 kilometers per second and as the
little equation C equals frequency times
wavelength what changes is the
see versus the wavelength when the
wavelength gets longer there there's
less frequency and when the frequency
increases the wavelength gets shorter
and asked the equation of a rope here's
a limited amount of rope right I torque
it see if I can target okay
very tight and you get lots of links and
each link is short now I am talk it okay
now every link has become longer we have
much fewer links in other words less
frequency and greater wavelength and
that's the equation of light light
always travels that little C at 300,000
kilometers per second so all that
happens between any two atoms whether
they go through a dense medium light
medium or whatever is that what we
change is the frequency before the
wavelength
there is no medium out there that you
know retards like retards of the speed
of light like you know again a particle
going through some kind of medium such
as water or molasses there's no such
thing it's not a particle trying to get
through molasses what it is is the
torsion changes in other words you
expand the link it becomes longer and
you have fewer links and so there is no
ether out there that's acting as a
molasses which is essentially what the
michelson-morley experiment they did a
series of experiments essentially showed
that there is no no background no no
bunch of particles the universe is not a
sandbox where light has to go through
different layers of sand you know more
dense sand here less things sand here
and so on and here you have a solid in
here you have a liquid in here you have
a gas and so light has a easier time to
go through gas and enhance through
solids why only because what changes is
the frequency of the wave length in each
one of the
there is no such thing as refractive
index as I like to say refractive index
is a Ptolemaic explanation for what
light is doing and if you know who
Ptolemy was you'll know what I'm talking
about
yep yeah I thought that actually and of
course a lot of those in physics the
well so called physics these days I
think they are so last question actually
go for that you actually already covered
them so okay lynch mobs always waiting
for me outside
oh thank you it's great although I might
have some questions asked if we might do
this again maybe we have some follow-up
questions from a fan for my listeners
they're behaving effect I'm sure they
will wait actually fair okay
hopefully someone is enlightened a
little bit and it has the curiosity to
go beyond what they've heard from the
establishment named look into this and
they say well okay you don't have to
believe in any all you have to do is
understand it that's what I'm saying and
maybe they go out there they understand
and say oh this is interesting
yeah at least it gives them a different
vision of the universe as a minimum I
think because you won't find us in the
official literature
none of us oh I have I have lots of
listeners and people who begin to
differently do that that's one of the
reasons I'm doing this so they can find
out or you get a good introduction to
your staff even maybe QE lamda is where
this takes off baby
so we do think I'll get back to you
maybe you know I'll show you the air
I'll show you this product when it's out
I think I'm really winded at least a
nice one I think is did you end up like
a weak thing this when I've first me out
so if you want to give you the lincoln
you can this heaven
listen to it if you want well I'm just
worried that the people in Auckland and
Christchurch and all these other places
down there then they don't come with a
rope and do something else with it
hopefully not